Well,
um,
my recent visit to Congo to the eastern
parts that is the north and South Kivu
revealed that there is still a rather
unstable situation,
uh,
in the east.
And um,
this was a followup to the atrocities in
the valley color territory.
I'm late August,
beginning of September,
and um,
I withdraw the worried to visit some of
these villages because I'm still.
People are traumatized and I'm in a kind
of,
in a state of shock,
I would say,
uh,
not only that,
but they fear that their attackers might
come back or even that the deployment of
a government troops in this area might
mean that they also have to live off the
population.
They are deployed there without enough
to eat,
without pay,
without a barracks.
So it means that they are afraid that
they will have to,
that they will start to loot and pillage
this,
these villages as,
as well.
And then we can assume rape.
Unfortunately,
this is actually a,
an area where a close to the mining
mining activities.
So the BCA,
a mining district.
So it means that,
uh,
some of the men from this small villages
probably work in the,
in the mining business or to support the
mining business,
but very often these small minds or
controlled by rebel groups or sometimes,
uh,
by,
by government troops as,
as well.
And um,
it means that it's a very sort of unsafe
situation for,
for civilians.
And uh,
unfortunately this is something that
fuels the,
the ongoing conflict and some of the
rebels.
So it leaves the civil population very
exposed and under a kind of constant
stress.
Well,
everybody said the same thing.
They want peace and they hope that piece
will bring peace also to the women.
Um,
this is not,
we cannot be sure that it brings peace
to the women because when this is done
at the scale that we saw in the editor,
oratory and in these villages,
uh,
unfortunately it brutalizes the whole
society.
It's been sober on the civil society.
And that means,
um,
you know,
a new generation of young men and boys
will also think that,
that this is a,
a natural thing.
And women don't feel that they have that
they are valued that they.
And one young woman said to us that she.
Her impression was that she was of
course very distraught,
but she said,
I a dead rat is worth more than the body
of a woman.
And,
and I think this just shows that at the
moment the women who are very much the
backbone of the economy of the DRC
are just sort of not valued.
They are,
they are broken.
And that means also it will be so much
more difficult to build peace and any
kind of economic development in the DRC.